forget about technique just get across as quickly
as you can I mean that's one heck of a save right
there no clue how he was able to stretch out
and get all the way back Kingbird for nander
down low across there's the back door play and
lei a brilliant stop watch Levi as soon as Mar
throws it across and forget about technique
just get across as quickly as you can almost
drops his stick there but got his glove in a good
position troch must score to extend the shootout
in against flurry and a save by flurry the Wild
winning in a shootout tro with a fake shot brings
the puck back to his forehead he's able to
dig in just enough I have no clue how at 38
years old he was able to stretch out and get all
the way back across to keep that one out but he
did it's Hall and Johnson Taylor Hall for
Johnson oh what a stop stoar spread out well
here's the best save that we've seen all night
what a stretch there perfectly timed beautiful
save hits Levine Schwarz Everly turned out
Lenard lard miraculous stop on windberg what
a save by big number 80 wber actually got a
real good shot off of The Rolling Puck too
wow I mean that's one heck of a save right
there Shay looking for deflection comes back
Martin no stall and soken highlight re save
on the can's captain now he's got to come
back right and still has the wherewithal
to spot that puck from stall as gets it
with his blocker the big white blocker gets it
right there and another big save for the goal
tender moved along for Nyquist a shot bought
off the rebound grow comes up big on no back
GR B Standing Tall this Save Right Here tells
me gr Bow's ready full extension able to make
that [Music] save back out High dumlin shoots is
it in no side of the net Keller might have saved
a goal you betcha referee in perfect position a
defensive gem right here getting back this puck
in the crease in ready across the line and then
a great save by Ingram to stop the second chance
he'll get it back from power side of the net
Theo out in front for KBS and oh my goodness
on T Mercy he just robbed Payton Krebs blind
his best save of the year no doubt about it
now a chance for a break Ron comes all the way
out the pl away from mid and then R the Kane
somehow survived that and r in the middle of it
all and Auntie R every period has made a huge
save here he comes out on Casey middlest stat
and then he finds a way selling out to make a
save pass to the side Tyler s in front Demco
great save loose Puck and they couldn't put
home now Johnson oh Demco with the glove twice
on that sequence he robbed Wyatt Johnson but the
second one was simply unbelievable my goodness
Thatcher with the catcher thought they'd have
t go down and out and look at this my goodness
and chock that up to a beauty of the week two
on one Dickson Tyler Johnson what a save by
vanich he was completely airborne and there
you see where the goal tender here now he's got
to get up dive desperately and he does drop his
stick on purpose to make sure that he can
get his glove over there out of Dominic
hasik Carlson snapshot on the way kicked out
rebound scolling kick out save by m leak was
Dynamite on Keta and what a split save there by
m leakin power play the of M One Stop samsonov
moves all the way across the crease and then the
left Club flashes out with a great stop back to
the line it's leang cing out R and a great save
by Gibson as a one fromel does not get through
his former teammate John Gibson's been terrific
this is a highquality stop on the one-time real
good stop by John here's Len man with a Chance
Anderson sto by SOS came across to shut down the
near side as Anderson had a good look there to
make it a one goal game what lateral movement
from Saros beautiful save rer to the net Z bad
fls it there and it's fought off by whoo Ryder
got to that Puck and whoo had to stretch for it
but this is an excellent save back for splitz
on the P walks right oh he got him scking
wide got to stick on that tuck was up and
out oh you could tell as soon as he stepped he
had him empty net shot oh what a stop there by
San unbelievable passing by the Maple Leafs does
not result in a goal this is a swayan save again
up to Anderson shot save made rebound juggled
it fell behind but sure it's loose and what
a carnival in the Dallas crease Andre laughing
it off it flips over top of him he turns around
High gets Big Time skate save help from ASA
Lindell activity last night south of here out
in front it's loose save by Wedgewood it looked
like Newen Hopkins had a wide open net to stuff
it in here's Robertson again plays it in front
great save markstrom absolutely robs Joe pavelski
you can't believe it well another one for the
markstrom Highlight Reel this season he's been
unbelievable and that one was fantastic Point
position seon finds his man man tremendous save
by lingren I thought it was a layup on the far
side he was so wide open didn't get it up in the
air there lingren Stone Cole Rob marchenko and
the recovery and the compete level of lingren
Joe